hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing some youtube
videos where i want to share with you
guys all my experience
and i want to show you guys how i do my
analysis and how i build up my views
on the different stocks so if you guys
want to know
the different tools and techniques that
pro trader is actually using to make
money on the markets
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on
amc because i heard a lot of stuff about
that
in the comments of my previous videos
and i want to discuss that with you
today
let's get into it
[Music]
so very uh quickly the first thing amc
is going higher
the past two days it took around
40 all right so it looks like we are
actually buttoned here around 5 50 and
we are going higher so
i'm just gonna discuss with you guys
first the news
why we went higher and i want to discuss
again with you guys
this very controversial topic which is
the short interest and i want to show
you
how i find out what is the correct data
amongst all the data
you can find on the internet and i'm
going to show you why
this is correct and how you can find it
by yourself
so let's start with the news so if you
want to know some news about any stock
i advise you guys to use something that
is free that you can find everywhere
which is yahoo finance guys
you just type amc here and you have all
the different articles
that are related to the stock and that
have uh
that explain why it went higher so the
first thing
that you can find is actually amazon
bang imc isn't as crazy as you think
so basically this is just a rumor but
this is the reason why
amc moved higher on thursday morning
because amazon could emerge as a
potential
suitor so they want to buy amc
why not i mean you know they give some
reasons why they should and some
reasons why they should not but this is
not really the question the good thing
guys is when a monster like amazon wants
to buy another monster like amc
this is very bullish for the market so
both stocks went higher what else can we
find
we can see here that the governor andrew
cuomo which is like the governor of new
york uh announced that big apple
theaters can reopen the first week of
march
all right guys this is very good news as
well you know if people start to
go back to cinema of course amc would um
start to make more money and it would be
better for them
the question is here guys about
when are actually gonna people able to
go back to the
cinema because as this guy which is an
analyst
who is analyst says here the desire to
head out to movies might be overcome by
caution while cinema goers
wait until they are vaccinated so don't
forget guys
we are in the uh kovit crisis so if you
think that all the vaccines we have
pfizer moderna astrazeneca actually
gonna be efficient
uh against the different variants that
we have you know the britain variants
the south african variants then
of course you think that in 2021 or 22
the covet process will be finished
but of course this is not sure we don't
know what other variants we're going to
have and if those vaccines
which are for now efficient against
those variants would still be efficient
again
the new variants because guys let me
remind you how a virus is actually
working
you know there are always mutations you
know which create those variants
and those who actually survive are those
who can
live longer so if we have those vaccines
that kill
this kind of variant there might be
another one that is actually a
resistance to the way
we uh fight the virus and that can maybe
start to grow i hope it's not going to
be the case i'm just saying that we
don't know and that this
would be very important for imc to
recover
fully now let's discuss about you know
what happened on my older youtube videos
guys
so i had a lot of comments
coming from you know people like matt
herback
all right so this guy is basically
saying junk video
thank you bro appreciate uh classic
mopass
asking me if i smoke bad uh then this
guy
met her herbeck again saying uh that
there is 0.08 percent of the float left
to buy
let's see if this guy uh say something
that is true
and and let's find out this is going to
squeeze
hard so he's believing there's gonna be
a short squeeze
uh this dude talking about me has no
clue what he's talking about
all right uh they're lying about the
short interest with
false reports so this guy doesn't
understand anything
let's try to find who he is all right so
if i go on linkedin
at that mat her bags
okay i can find this guy no information
so basically you don't you can't find
this guy on linkedin for now
but you know this is definitely not uh
someone that is working in finance and
that knows what he's talking about
we have otherwise uh here eric
arvizu that is saying short interest on
imc's higher all right
so i found eric avizu this is this guy
he looks actually quite educated
houston community college bachelor's
degree
lead technician you know he's an
engineer all right and he thinks
that uh but at least he's you know
polite and he's saying short interest on
amc is
higher let's find out guys all these
people they got their data so you can
find this data on
market beat market watch bloomberg any
kind of
website that is providing information
about stocks and i know where they found
the data
they go on market watch all right they
think
the short interest is 66 why
because it's the number of shares 37.7
million
divided by the public floats all right
the public float is the shares you can
trade with during the day and they
think that the shares outstanding the
total number of shares is
330 million so basically 37 divided by
57
gives 66 but funny thing guys
uh is that when i look at for example
market bids
and i go under short interest i can see
37.7 million as well
here but the short interest is 17
why because the total outstanding shares
is higher
so let's find out who is correct and so
guys i took this data and i checked what
we had
uh you know history clip and when you
look historically guys if for the past
year so i have here the total number of
shares sorry the
shares available for training so the
equity float without sending shares
which is the total number of shares
the short interest which is the number
of shares that is short and i added some
information
for you guys to be able to actually spot
what is the correct data and what is not
so i added the daily volume and then i
computed by myself
just the division the public shares the
public shares as a percentage of their
standing share so it's like how much
shares can you actually trade amongst
the total number of shares so it's just
this
uh equity flow divided by outstanding
shares and i computed the short interest
which is actually the total
number of short shares divided by the
shares you can trade which is the equity
float
and what i see is that the public shares
as a performance
percentage of the total number of shares
is always around 98
then you can see that basically it was
around 55 million
you know last year and that suddenly it
started to grow
together of course you know every two
weeks we have the
this information updated so the last
update uh
is only on the 29th of january on all
the websites the next one is coming
actually today guys
and you can see that it went uh as high
as 400 million shares
so when marketwatch is saying that we
have 57 million
shares of public float you can see that
they are stuck on the
value of october 20 guys six months ago
so they just didn't update the data all
right so they are right on the total
number of short shares which is 37
million but they forget to see
that the equity float just increased by
300 percent
around so another interesting thing is
to see that
actually you know when did they raise
these shares guys
during all this rally actually here so
this is october
all right so between so it was at five
so between october and
the 29th of january which is actually
somewhere around here
uh we had around uh you know the total
number of shots was multiplied by
eight guys like from 50 to 400 like
seven
eight whatever and the reason behind
guys look
we are even having news on this is that
uh you know so the president nco adam
aaron of amc
is saying that after raising nearly 1
billion in capital this means that
any talk of an imminent bankruptcy is of
the table all right for amc
they basically raised money through
equity so the emitted shares that
diluted their current
shareholders uh shares like value
and and they meet in new shares because
guys this company is
so here at the earnings is losing around
4 billion annually so of course they
need money to pay the debt
of like all the capacity they need money
to pay the debt
of all the cinema in the united states
everywhere in the world so this is the
reason why they emit shares and they
emitted here guys at a very high price
all right that's not a surprise when
your share is that
high it's the right time to actually
emit chas
and make some cash enter in the cashier
so i just would like to come back guys
to this value that is 66
that is wrong all right the correct uh
value guys is 37 million
divided by 400 million shares which is
right now the total outstanding shares
i want to show you one more thing guys
about that so here guys you have the
daily volume
so the daily volume is the number of
shares exchanged
every day during the training sessions
and you can see that it's around 50
million all right this data is available
everywhere
so how come do you think it's possible
that the daily volume of shares is 50
million
when the total number of shares
available for
for trading would be as market watch is
saying 57 million
all right this doesn't make any sense
guys when it was 57 million
the total the daily volume was 4 million
all right so the daily volume of shares
got multiplied by 10
and the equity float got multiplied by
eight all right seven
eight so this makes sense so once again
guys when you see that the short
interest on amc
is around 60 this is completely wrong
when you see people
that tell you that there is almost no
more shares to borrow in order to take a
short position this is all wrong guys
the short interest is only 10 right now
all right
back from 70 in october it was 70
all the hedge funds kept the position
because right now look
at what those guys are doing if you go
on market beats and you go to
institutional ownership this is very
interesting information guys
institutional clients are asset managers
hedge funds all right
so during 2020 there was selling amc
all right you can see that the red bar
is higher than the
than the green bar so they were selling
amc massively
and right now what are they doing guys
they are buying it all right
first quarter they are buyers you know
because the fundamentals come back
because there are some good news amazon
is maybe
willing to buy it so to me this uh is
showing actually that
uh this stock has a more natural bias
than it used to to to have before the
short interest is
has come back to very decent levels and
i expect the stock to just
do what it's meant to to do so let me
finish on the technicals guys uh as i've
gone through
all this information with you so
technically what do we see guys we had
this breakout
we broke it and now we have retested it
already
and we are pushing higher so where our
key areas of support and resistance
so as i said in my previous video five
550 was a strong support
it acted like this and we saw a very
um nice move up around 40 percent
right now we have a resistance at 750
okay this
orange line because it's actually uh the
level where we had
the three uh most recent maximums before
this uh big breakout so one two three
even here guys you can see it acted as
resistance so this level is going to be
a resistance to overcome
but i'm pretty confident that amc would
overcome it and push higher
because once again in the long term guys
we
have this breakout that is retested that
acted again
as support and we saw a lot of buying
flows coming in the game
at this levels so this is showing me
guys that
there is really really a lot of people
that
want to buy the stock and hold it so i'm
pretty sure that right now
we are going to go to the next fib
extension
ratios so to know them you just measure
the first wave
and you apply it to the bottom of the
second wave all right and
what you can see is that you have
different ratios so the most common one
is the 1.618
so this is my target for amc guys so i
think that within one year or even a few
months
we might go there so around 500 percent
higher
i wouldn't say i'm very you know
convinced but this is my preferred
scenario all right this is my preferred
scenario that we are actually going to
do 1.618 uh fib extension ratio
but i wouldn't buy imc at this level
if you guys want to buy it you should
wait uh
you could wait for you know a breakout
of the 750
resistance and then some conservation
will probably take place here
and then we would move ultimately higher
and this would be the right time to buy
the stock
and if it comes back to five it's again
a very nice level to buy
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i hope you understood
how i actually make the difference
between the fake data
and the good data all right just by
checking you know what is making sense
in the market the daily volume of shares
traded
the total outstanding shares the public
float and the number of shares that is
showed
and given all this information you can
know for sure that the total short
interest
on imc is around 10 so that's it for me
guys stay close to shore